that comment about testing definitely
stood out because right now we turn to
alarming numbers in the corona virus
pandemic those numbers have set records
the largest increase in cases since May
1st that is just over the weekend one
especially hard-hit state is Florida
where cases have been rising steadily
for weeks that's where the president
plans to deliver his acceptance speech
during the republican national
convention that's coming up in august
Manuel Bojorquez is in Miami Forrest
many good morning how are state
officials responding to this increase
good morning governor Ron DeSantis said
he will begin to crack down on bars that
are overcrowded and restaurants that are
not following social distancing
guidelines this comes after the most
recent data shows that increasingly
young people are testing positive which
some experts blame on a lack of a
mandatory facemask rule and lacks
attitudes about social distancing and
after blaming the rise in cases here on
increased testing this weekend the
governor reversed course even with
testing increasing or being flat the
number of people testing positive is
accelerating faster than that
Florida Governor Ron de Santos says even
as Florida's record-breaking run of new
cases continues there are no plans to
slow Florida's reopening or implement a
mandatory mask order we just got to
trust people I think that that tends to
work better than to mandate this mandate
that but as cases rise statewide some
cities like Tampa and Orlando are
implementing mask orders of their own
the rise in cases caused major league
baseball to close all training camps in
Florida and Arizona for deep cleaning
and in Tampa players on both the
professional football and hockey teams
tested positive within the last week
forcing team facilities to close for
disinfecting we opened too quickly our
urgency to open from phase 1 to phase 2
was fueled by again the economy dr.
Marsha Katz is the chief medical officer
at the University of Central Florida
health
she says Kovan related hospitalizations
are up across the Orlando area and even
though young people account from
of the rise in cases their ability to
spread the virus is still a threat to
public health do you anticipate that in
two weeks given the number of new cases
that we're seeing the hospitals will
definitely see more patients yes I
anticipate that Florida is one of at
least seven states where the seven-day
average of positive tests is over ten
percent well above the World Health
Organization's recommended five percent
for reopening 'he's former FDA
Commissioner Scott Gottlieb said on Face
the Nation Sunday that getting outbreaks
under control without new lockdown
orders will be challenging we can do
case-based interventions the tracking
and the tracing of sick people to get
people isolated we can go towards
universal masking something that's been
controversial in some of these states
but there's not much else you can do and
as President Donald Trump publicly
claims the virus is disappearing White
House trade advisor Peter Navarro said
the administration is already preparing
for a second wave we are filling the
stockpile in anticipation of a possible
problem in the fall we're doing
everything we can beneath the surface
working as hard as we possibly can in
the meantime the organizer of several
recent protests in South Carolina is
urging people who participated to get
tested for kovat 19 after several
protesters tested positive in light of
those recent cases several upcoming
protests have been canceled
Anthony Manny thank you